The secret to Charlotte Cardin's captivating eyes? Panorama Mascara by L'Oreal Paris. The multi-level bristle brush catches every lash from inner to outer corner. For panoramic volume with lashes that are so fanned out, eyes appear 1.4 times bigger. See life in panorama because you're worth it. Shop L'Oreal-Paris Panorama Mascara on Amazon now. Did you know that Staples Professional can tailor a custom program
夏洛特·卡丹（Charlotte Cardin）迷人双眸的秘诀是什么？欧莱雅巴黎全景睫毛膏。多层刷毛刷头能捕捉从内眼角到外眼角的每一根睫毛。打造全景浓密效果，睫毛极度展开，双眼看起来大1.4倍。以全景视角看生活，因为你值得拥有。立即在亚马逊上购买欧莱雅巴黎全景睫毛膏。你知道史泰博专业服务（Staples Professional）可以量身定制专属方案吗？
to make running your business easy? With a Staples Professional account, you get one vendor, one delivery, and one invoice for all your must-haves, from tech to cleaning supplies, and dedicated support from Staples experts who guide you on everything from product selection and ordering to payment. Join today at staplesprofessional.ca and get expert solutions tailored to your business. That was easy. Investing is all about the future. So what do you think is going to happen? Bitcoin is sort of inevitable at this point?
让您的业务运营变得轻松？拥有史泰博专业账户，您只需一个供应商、一次配送、一张发票，即可搞定从科技产品到清洁用品的所有必需品，并获得史泰博专家的专属支持，为您提供从产品选择、订购到付款的全方位指导。立即访问 staplesprofessional.ca 加入，获取为您业务量身定制的专家解决方案。就是这么简单。投资关乎未来。那么你认为会发生什么呢？比特币在这一点上可以说是不可避免的吗？
I think it would come down to precious metals. I hope we don't go cashless. I would say land is a safe investment. Technology companies. Solar energy. Robotic pollinators might be a thing. A wrestler to face a robot? That will have to happen.
我认为这会归结为贵金属。我希望我们不要走向无现金化。我会说土地是一项安全的投资。科技公司。太阳能。机器人授粉可能成为现实。摔跤手对战机器人？这一定会发生。
So whatever you think is going to happen in the future, you can invest in it at WealthSimple. Start now at WealthSimple.com. On the battlefield of Can I, the victorious Hannibal was surrounded by his officers. They were all congratulating him and urging him to take things easy for the rest of the day and the night and to allow his exhausted troops to do the same. But Mahabal, his captain of horse, had a very different take on the situation, for he was convinced that not a moment was to be
所以无论你认为未来会发生什么，你都可以在 WealthSimple 进行投资。立即访问 WealthSimple.com 开始。在坎尼战场上，凯旋的汉尼拔被他的军官们包围了。他们都在祝贺他，并敦促他在这天余下的时间和夜里好好休息，也让疲惫的军队这样做。但他的骑兵队长马哈巴尔（Mahabal）对局势有着截然不同的看法，因为他确信一刻也不能
lost. My lord, he declared, if you wish to understand properly what you have secured with this victory, then let me tell you that within five days you will be feasting in triumph on the capital in Rome. I will go ahead with my horsemen. The first the Romans will know of the fate about to overwhelm them will be the sight of our cavalry at the gates of their city. All you have to do is to follow where we lead. But to Hannibal, this seemed altogether too optimistic, too ambitious a plan. while I commend your spirit, he said to Mahabal, I need time to evaluate what you are suggesting, to which Mahabal retorted.
耽误。大人，他宣称，如果您想真正理解这场胜利为您带来了什么，那么请让我告诉您，五天之内，您将在罗马首都举行凯旋盛宴。我将带着我的骑兵先行一步。罗马人即将面临的命运，他们最先看到的将是我们出现在他们城门口的骑兵。您所要做的就是跟随我们前进的方向。但对汉尼拔来说，这似乎是一个过于乐观、过于雄心勃勃的计划。虽然我赞赏你的精神，他对马哈巴尔说，但我需要时间来评估你的建议，马哈巴尔反驳道。
Gifts are never lavished by the gods in their entirety on a single man. You know Hannibal how to win a battle, but you do not know how to use your victory. So, a very celebrated moment in ancient history. This is the aftermath of the most notorious, the most shattering defeat ever suffered by a Roman army. And this is being reported two centuries later by the historian Livy. So to give people a little bit of context. The battle in question was the Battle of Cannae. It was fought on the 2nd of August 21st, 216 BC.
神灵从不会将礼物全部赐予一个人。汉尼拔，你知道如何赢得一场战斗，但你不知道如何利用你的胜利。所以，这是古代历史上一个非常著名的时刻。这是罗马军队有史以来遭受的最臭名昭著、最惨痛的失败后的余波。这是两个世纪后由历史学家李维（Livy）记录下来的。为了给人们一点背景信息。所说的这场战役是坎尼会战（Battle of Cannae）。它发生于公元前216年8月2日。
And it resulted in the almost total annihilation of the largest army that the Roman Republic had ever put into the field. And last year, Tom, in our episode on the Battle of Can I, episode 571, for people who were interested in that kind of thing, you came up with some extraordinary facts to illustrate just how industrial the slaughter at Can I was. So the Romans suffered more casualties at Can I, if the ancient historians are to be believed, than the British army had suffered on the first day of the Somme, or the Americans had suffered in the entire Vietnam War. the stakes in this war between Rome and Carthage are that high. Absolutely. And if Can I is the worst defeat in Rome's history, it is the greatest victory ever won by their enemies, the Carthaginians led by their great General Hannibal, still only just 30 when he won that victory.
它导致了罗马共和国有史以来投入战场的最庞大军队几乎全军覆没。去年，汤姆，在我们关于坎尼会战的第571期节目中，对于那些对此感兴趣的人，你提出了一些非凡的事实，说明了坎尼的屠杀是多么工业化。如果古代历史学家可信的话，罗马人在坎尼遭受的伤亡比英国军队在索姆河战役第一天遭受的伤亡，或者美国人在整个越南战争中遭受的伤亡还要多。罗马和迦太基之间这场战争的赌注就是这么高。绝对是。如果坎尼是罗马历史上最惨痛的失败，那么它也是他们的敌人——由伟大的将军汉尼拔领导的迦太基人——所赢得的最伟大的胜利，他赢得这场胜利时年仅30岁。
And it's the apoge of Hannibal's career. It's also, in a sense, the apogee of Carthaginian power. because from this point onwards, it's going to be downhill for Carthage and indeed for Hannibal. And it will culminate in 146 BC. So, you know, not many decades later in the complete annihilation of Carthage. And we're going to be telling the story of how we go from Can I to the complete destruction of the city in the next four episodes. An amazingly dramatic story, one of the most exciting that we've ever done. But put us into a bit of context here.
这是汉尼拔职业生涯的巅峰。从某种意义上说，这也是迦太基权力的巅峰。因为从这一点开始，迦太基乃至汉尼拔都将走下坡路。它将在公元前146年达到顶点。所以，你知道，没过几十年，迦太基就被彻底消灭了。在接下来的四集里，我们将讲述我们如何从坎尼走向这座城市的彻底毁灭。一个令人惊叹的戏剧性故事，是我们做过的最激动人心的故事之一。但请先给我们一点背景介绍。
So the great city of Carthage. So Carthage for centuries has been the queen of the Western Mediterranean, hasn't it? The backstory essentially is that Carthage, for centuries, had ruled as the mistress of the Western Mediterranean. By far its most formidable naval power. She has tremendous natural advantages. Great harbors, a fertile hinterland. She is on the tip of what is now Tunis. So opposite Sicily and her position there enables her to dominate those crucial straits.
伟大的迦太基城。几个世纪以来，迦太基一直是西地中海的女王，不是吗？背景本质上是，几个世纪以来，迦太基一直统治着西地中海，是无可争议的女主人。它是迄今为止最强大的海军力量。她拥有巨大的自然优势。优良的港口，肥沃的腹地。她位于现在突尼斯的最尖端。所以与西西里岛相对，她在那里占据的位置使她能够控制那些关键的海峡。
And traditionally, her great enemies were not the Romans, but the Greeks who had planted a whole host of colonies in the island of Sicily. And the most formidable of these colonies was a city that is still very much to be found in Sicily to this day, the city of Syracuse on the southeastern corner of the island. And exactly like Carthage, Syracuse boasted tremendous natural advantages. So again, a superb natural harbour, rocky heights and plateaus, very defensible. And again, like Carthage, a very commanding position on kind of the key shipping lanes that run throughout the Mediterranean, joining the western and eastern halves of the sea.
传统上，她最大的敌人不是罗马人，而是那些在西西里岛建立了大量殖民地的希腊人。这些殖民地中最强大的是一座至今仍能在西西里岛找到的城市——位于该岛东南角的叙拉古（Syracuse）。和迦太基一样，叙拉古也拥有巨大的自然优势。同样，一个极好的天然港口，岩石高地和高原，非常易守难攻。同样像迦太基一样，它在贯穿地中海、连接海洋东西两半的关键航线上占据着非常重要的位置。
So Carthage and Syracuse are very evenly matched, and they're always fighting each other. But these wars are not wars to the death. They actually remind me of the old firm, Rangers and Celtic in the Scottish Premiership. One of them always wins, but they never established a kind of absolutely permanent commanding supremacy over the other. And that's basically the relationship between Carthage and Syracuse for, you know, for centuries and centuries. But then in the third century BC, a new kid arrives on the block and this is the Roman Republic.
所以迦太基和叙拉古实力相当，他们总是互相争斗。但这些战争并非你死我活的战争。它们实际上让我想起了苏格兰超级联赛中的老字号球队——流浪者队和凯尔特人队。其中一方总是获胜，但他们从未对另一方建立起某种绝对永久的统治地位。这就是几个世纪以来迦太基和叙拉古之间的基本关系。但到了公元前三世纪，一个新角色登场了，这就是罗马共和国。
I mean, to pursue the kind of the football analogy, I guess it's. as though, I don't know, Aberdeen were to be taken over by the Saudis and pumped full of money, and then suddenly they start winning. Because in 264 BC, the Romans get embroiled in a kind of minor squabble over treaty rights, and they massively escalate it into a full-blown war with Carthage. And this is the war that the Romans call the Punic War, because Punicus is the Latin for Carthaginian. Carthaginians originally came from Phoenicia in what is now Lebanon, and so it's a kind of derivation from Phoenician. This war went on for 23 years, didn't it?
我的意思是，继续用足球类比的话，我想这就像是，我不知道，阿伯丁队被沙特人收购并注入大量资金，然后突然开始获胜。因为在公元前264年，罗马人卷入了一场关于条约权利的小争执，并将其大规模升级为与迦太基的全面战争。这就是罗马人所说的布匿战争（Punic War），因为 Punicus 是迦太基人的拉丁语。迦太基人最初来自现在黎巴嫩的腓尼基，所以这是一种源自腓尼基语的词汇。这场战争持续了23年，不是吗？
It was the longest war in classical antiquity, and it's the ultimate clash between a sea power and a land power. And the Carthaginians, I suppose, if you're a betting man at the beginning, are the favourites, but astonishingly the Romans forced them at the end of these 23 years to sue for terms. terms and remind us how the Romans did it? Well, the Romans have immense reserves of manpower. So they are now the dominant power in Italy. And they have essentially constructed this framework of alliances.
这是古典时代持续时间最长的战争，也是海权国家与陆权国家之间的终极较量。我想，如果你在开始时是一个赌徒，迦太基人是热门，但令人惊讶的是，在这23年后，罗马人迫使他们求和。提醒我们罗马人是怎么做到的？嗯，罗马人拥有巨大的兵力储备。所以他们现在是意大利的主导力量。他们本质上构建了这个联盟框架。
Defeated cities are offered various degrees of citizenship or associated status. And essentially, loyalty on the part of defeated cities to Rome is very amply rewarded. They get given chunks of spoil or whatever. Also, the Romans have an incredibly. dogged, in fact, implacable resolve never to accept defeat, never even to accept disrespect. It's a kind of almost a kind of mafia attitude. And the classic example of how far they are prepared to go in the search of victory is the fact that even though they are the elephant to Carthage's wail, over the course of this, the first Punic War, as it comes to be called, they transform themselves into a naval power. I mean, they do it in a slightly makeshift way.
战败的城市被提供不同程度的公民身份或附属地位。本质上，战败城市对罗马的忠诚会得到非常丰厚的回报。他们会得到战利品或其他东西。此外，罗马人有一种令人难以置信的、顽强的、甚至是不可动摇的决心，绝不接受失败，甚至绝不接受不尊重。这几乎是一种黑手党式的态度。他们为了寻求胜利愿意走多远的一个经典例子是，尽管他们是迦太基的“鲸鱼”面前的“大象”，但在第一次布匿战争期间，他们将自己转型为一支海军力量。我的意思是，他们做得有点临时凑合。
They find a galley and it's like a kind of IKEA flat pack and this is how they build their fleet. But they just go on and on and on. And by the end of it, they've won. And the treaty that they force on Carthage in 241 BC essentially institutionalises Roman control of Sicily. And this is a key moment in the emergence of what will become the Roman Empire. because a large swath of the island, about three quarters of it, comes under the authority, in Latin, the provincia of a Roman governor. And this word provincia is the word from which the English word province will ultimately derive.
他们找到了一艘桨帆船，就像宜家那种平板包装家具，这就是他们建造舰队的方式。但他们只是不断地坚持下去。到最后，他们赢了。他们在公元前241年强加给迦太基的条约，本质上制度化了罗马对西西里岛的控制。这是后来成为罗马帝国的崛起中的一个关键时刻。因为该岛的一大部分，大约四分之三，处于罗马总督的权威之下，在拉丁语中称为 provincia。这个词 provincia 就是英语单词 province（省）最终的来源。
So in effect, kind of the three quarters of Sicily that the Romans have seized becomes Rome's first overseas province. And this treaty, so we're in 241 BC, the country. Carthaginians, this great naval power in the Western Mediterranean, have been defeated unexpectedly. They've signed this treaty, agreed this treaty with the Romans. And this treaty, you could liken it, I suppose, to the Treaty of Versailles or something, because it's often said when people are talking about the origins of the Second World War, that they were kind of implicit in the way the First World War ended, because the very punitive treaty that the Allies forced on the Germans meant that the Germans were bound to seek revenge or redress at some point.
所以实际上，罗马人夺取的西西里岛四分之三的土地成为了罗马的第一个海外行省。这份条约，我们现在是在公元前241年。迦太基人，这个西地中海的海上强国，出人意料地战败了。他们签署了这份条约，与罗马人达成了这份条约。你可以把这份条约比作凡尔赛条约之类的东西，因为当人们谈论第二次世界大战的起源时，常说它们隐含在第一次世界大战结束的方式中，因为盟军强加给德国人的惩罚性条约意味着德国人注定要在某个时候寻求复仇或补偿。
And do you think this is true of Carthage as well, that basically the first Punic War means there's bound to be a second one? I think so. I think there are kind of certain parallels with the Versailles Treaty because Carthage loses a lot of territory. She's forced out of Sicily permanently. And Sicily had always been the place where she went for her sporting contests with Syracuse. This is no longer going to happen. And also there is a very, very punitive indemnity which takes the Carthaginians a long time to pay. enormous resentment. But this settlement is actually quite bad news for Syracuse as well, because Syracuse had allied herself with Rome, but she ends the war rather like Britain
你认为这对迦太基也适用吗，即基本上第一次布匿战争意味着注定会有第二次？我想是的。我认为这与凡尔赛条约有一定的相似之处，因为迦太基失去了大量领土。她被永久地赶出了西西里岛。而西西里岛一直是她与叙拉古进行体育竞技的地方。这种情况将不再发生。而且还有一个非常、非常惩罚性的赔款，迦太基人花了很长时间才付清。巨大的怨恨。但这个解决方案对叙拉古来说实际上也是个坏消息，因为叙拉古曾与罗马结盟，但她结束战争的方式很像英国
ends the Second World War in relation to America. So Syracuse is a natural ally for Rome, and she emerges pretty secure as a friend of their own republic. So the reason that the Romans only occupy three quarters of Sicily is that that other quarter is territory that belongs to Syracuse and is recognized as such by Rome. But it is clear that relative to Rome, Syracuse no longer ranks as a great power. And that means that rather like Britain in the wake of the Second World War, Syracuse is obsessed with maintaining a special relationship with the new superpower. So the Syracusans, their harbours are open to Roman galleys. If the Romans are short of manpower or of grain or supplies or whatever,
在第二次世界大战中相对于美国的方式。所以叙拉古是罗马的天然盟友，她作为罗马共和国的朋友相当稳固地出现了。罗马人只占领西西里岛四分之三的原因是，另外四分之一是属于叙拉古的领土，并被罗马承认。但很明显，相对于罗马，叙拉古不再被视为大国。这意味着，就像第二次世界大战后的英国一样，叙拉古痴迷于维持与这个新超级大国的特殊关系。所以叙拉古人，他们的港口对罗马桨帆船开放。如果罗马人缺乏人力、粮食或补给，
the Syracusans will go to great lengths to meet the needs of Rome. And to remind people the Syracusans, they're Greek speakers. They are Greeks. This is a Greek foundation, yes. So the Carthaginians, there is no possibility whatsoever of them pursuing a policy of accommodation with Rome. So there are obviously people who think, well, we don't want to poke the beast too soon. But by and large, would you say the mood in Carthage is one that we will rebuild, would take our time, but we will get our revenge? I think probably, yes. Certainly there are,
叙拉古人会竭尽全力满足罗马的需求。提醒一下，叙拉古人是讲希腊语的。他们是希腊人。这是一个希腊殖民地，是的。所以对于迦太基人来说，他们根本不可能采取与罗马妥协的政策。所以显然有些人认为，嗯，我们不想太早去招惹这头野兽。但总的来说，你会说迦太基的情绪是“我们会重建，我们会花时间，但我们会复仇”吗？我想大概是的。当然有，
so Carthage like Rome has a Senate, a kind of an assembly of its greatest and most influential men. And most of the people on this Carthaginian Senate, as you say, are, I think, reluctant in the immediate aftermath of the war to kind of return to open confrontation with Rome. But there is one family that is very keen to do this and it's the greatest and the most glamorous of all the dynasties of Carthage. And this is a family called the Barcids. And Barker is, it means lightning. And it's a name that has been given to the city's greatest general, who's a man called Hamilcar. And he's pretty much the only Carthaginian general to have emerged from the war with Rome with much credit. So he had fought a brilliant rearguard action in Sicily, trying to keep
所以迦太基像罗马一样有一个元老院，一种由其最伟大和最有影响力的人组成的议会。正如你所说，这个迦太基元老院中的大多数人，我认为在战争刚结束时，不愿回到与罗马的公开对抗中。但有一个家族非常热衷于这样做，它是迦太基所有王朝中最伟大、最迷人的。这就是一个叫巴卡（Barcids）的家族。Barker 的意思是闪电。这个名字被赋予了该市最伟大的将军，一个叫哈米尔卡（Hamilcar）的人。他是几乎唯一一个在与罗马的战争中获得很高声誉的迦太基将军。所以他在西西里岛进行了一场精彩的后卫战，试图阻止
the Romans at bay. The fact that he ultimately failed doesn't impair. his reputation for what had been a pretty good war. And Hamukar, in the wake of Carthage's defeat, decides that there is a need to find a replacement for Sicily, a new base for empire. And so he fixes on Spain and he builds a very substantial empire there. And he dies there fighting against Spanish, Iberian warriors. But he has three sons to succeed him. And the eldest of these is Hannibal, the famous general who will win the Battle of Can I. The two other sons, and Mago, and they will also feature in the war that Hannibal launches against Rome, because Hamelcar dies in battle in 229, and Hannibal proves a very, very worthy air to his father.
罗马人。他最终失败的事实并没有损害他作为一场相当不错的战争的声誉。哈米尔卡在迦太基战败后，决定需要为西西里岛寻找替代品，一个新的帝国基地。于是他看中了西班牙，并在那里建立了一个非常庞大的帝国。他在那里与西班牙、伊比利亚战士作战时阵亡。但他有三个儿子继承他。其中长子是汉尼拔，那位将赢得坎尼会战的著名将军。另外两个儿子是哈斯德鲁巴和马戈，他们也将出现在汉尼拔发动的对罗马的战争中，因为哈米尔卡于公元前229年在战斗中阵亡，而汉尼拔证明了他父亲非常、非常称职的继承人。
And by the 220s BC, he's built on the foundations laid by his father, and he has fashioned Spain into a very formidable launchpad for attacking Rome and for launching what he obviously sees as a kind of war of vengeance. Well, he has a new Carthage, doesn't he? Because they've got this dazzling new capital with harbors and city walls and fortifications and so on. He didn't build it himself, but he's inherited it. Yes. And so it's called Carthage, but the Romans will call it new Carthage. And I think it's easier for us to follow the Roman example. And as you say, it is modelled on the original Carthage and it is impressive in the way that the original Carthage is. And people may be wondering, well, how can this be afforded? Well, it can be afforded because Spain is massively rich in mineral wealth. There is gold, there is silver, there is copper, there is tin, there is lead. There's basically everything that you could possibly want. And the gold and silver
到了公元前220年代，他在父亲奠定的基础上进行了建设，并将西班牙打造成了一个非常强大的发射台，用于攻击罗马，并启动他显然视为一种复仇战争的行动。嗯，他有一个新迦太基，不是吗？因为他们拥有这个令人眼花缭乱的新首都，有港口、城墙和防御工事等等。他不是自己建造的，但他继承了它。是的。所以它被称为迦太基，但罗马人会称它为新迦太基。我认为我们遵循罗马人的例子更容易。正如你所说，它是仿照原来的迦太基建造的，它在令人印象深刻的程度上与原来的迦太基一样。人们可能想知道，这怎么负担得起？嗯，负担得起是因为西班牙拥有巨大的矿产财富。有金、银、铜、锡、铅。基本上你想要的一切都有。而金银
in particular can be used to recruit mercenaries. So infantry from Spain, the Spaniards are a very proficient fighters, infantry from Libya, cavalry from Numidia, which is basically now Algeria, which is by far the best like cavalry in the world. And Hannibal, by 218, is ready to take the Romans on. And very famously, he does this by taking the land route from Spain to Italy, complete with elephants, and he crosses the Alps. And this is probably the one thing that everyone knows about Hannibal. And he has with him his youngest brother, Mago.
特别是可以用来招募雇佣兵。所以来自西班牙的步兵，西班牙人是非常精锐的战士；来自利比亚的步兵；来自努米底亚（Numidia，基本上是现在的阿尔及利亚）的骑兵，这是迄今为止世界上最好的轻骑兵。到公元前218年，汉尼拔准备好挑战罗马人了。非常著名的是，他通过采取从西班牙到意大利的陆路，带着大象，并翻越了阿尔卑斯山。这可能是关于汉尼拔每个人都知道的一件事。他带着他最小的弟弟马戈。
He leaves Castro, his younger brother to Garrison, Spain. He also takes with him, someone we've met in the reading that you gave at the start of this program, Mahabal, who is probably Hannibal's nephew. And these are all very battle-hardened, seasoned, able men. And then the result of this, so he crosses the Alps, famously, elephants in tow, and he comes down into the plains of Italy, and he has a hat-trick of extraordinary victories. I mean, these are the victories that enshrine Hannibal's reputation as one of the greatest generals of all time and mean that, you know, if you're going to West Point or something, you will study Hannibal's tactics at Trebia at the Battle of Lake Trasamine and above all at the Battle of Can I, which is regarded as his greatest, his magnumopus, his greatest achievement. His masterpiece, in a sense, perhaps the most perfect battle ever fought. And the reason for that is that although he's outnumbered pretty much two to one, he so outsmart.
他留下哈斯德鲁巴，他的弟弟驻守西班牙。他还带上了我们在节目开始时你读到的那段文字中遇到的马哈巴尔，他可能是汉尼拔的侄子。这些都是久经沙场、经验丰富、能力出众的人。结果就是，他翻越了阿尔卑斯山，带着大象，进入了意大利平原，并取得了帽子戏法般的非凡胜利。我的意思是，这些胜利确立了汉尼拔作为有史以来最伟大将军之一的声誉，意味着，如果你去西点军校之类的学校，你将研究汉尼拔在特雷比亚（Trebia）、特拉西梅诺湖（Lake Trasimene）战役，尤其是坎尼会战中的战术，这被认为是他的最伟大成就，他的代表作。从某种意义上说，他的杰作，也许是有史以来最完美的战役。原因在于，尽管他的人数几乎是二比一的劣势，但他如此聪明地
his Roman opponents that his much smaller army is able to envelop the much larger Roman army and essentially wipe it out. Hannibal annihilates some 50 to 60,000 men on that single day, and it's one of the bloodiest single days of combat in the whole of military history. And it is this victory that is the backdrop to the famous confrontation between Hannibal and Mahabal that you read. And so you have to think that while Hannibal and Mahabal are having this conversation on the battlefield of Can I, the stench of the mass slaughter that has been inflicted that day is lying very heavy in the heat of the August evening. So they've been sick, they've voided their bowels, there's blood everywhere. Absolutely. The corpse is already starting to turn putrid in the heat.
智胜了他的罗马对手，以至于他规模小得多的军队能够包围规模大得多的罗马军队并基本上将其消灭。汉尼拔在那一天消灭了大约5到6万名士兵，这是整个军事史上最血腥的单日战斗之一。正是这场胜利成为了你读到的汉尼拔和马哈巴尔之间著名对峙的背景。所以你必须想到，当汉尼拔和马哈巴尔在坎尼战场上进行这次谈话时，那天造成的集体屠杀的恶臭在八月傍晚的炎热中弥漫。所以他们呕吐了，他们排泄了，到处都是血。绝对是。尸体在高温下已经开始腐烂。
And the dust, and everyone comments on the dust on the plane at Can I, so much blood has been evacuated that that dust is turning into a kind of mud. So it is a pretty hideous scene. So that conversation was reported by Livy two centuries later. And the obvious question, and indeed the question with so much classical history, is did this really happen or was Livy just following a kind of literary formula? Because this is the scene in which, you know, the Marjabal is saying to Hannibal, You know how to win, but you don't know how to win a battle, but you don't know how to win a war, you don't know how to press home your advantage and whatnot.
还有灰尘，每个人都评论坎尼平原上的灰尘，太多的血被排泄出来，灰尘变成了某种泥浆。所以这是一个相当可怕的场景。那段对话是两个世纪后由李维记录的。显而易见的问题，实际上也是许多古典历史中存在的问题，是这真的发生了，还是李维只是遵循了一种文学公式？因为这是马哈巴尔对汉尼拔说：“你知道如何赢得一场战斗，但你不知道如何赢得一场战争，你不知道如何利用你的优势”之类的场景。
And of course, lots of people listening to this podcast will know how this story ends, not least because we've talked about the fall of Carthage. So is there a case that basically Livy has created a literary set piece here to explain for us why Hannibal doesn't win? It's interesting. I think a surprising number of historians seem to take it as possibly expressing an authentic tradition. And even if it doesn't, then the reason that it has the kind of resonance that it does, I mean, it's one of the iconic moments in ancient history is because it does focus on this obvious question. Why didn't Hannibal take advantage of his great victory to advance immediately on Rome? Because we've said his family named Barker means lightning.
当然，听这个播客的许多人会知道这个故事是如何结束的，不仅因为我们谈到了迦太基的陷落。那么，有没有可能基本上李维在这里创造了一个文学片段来向我们解释为什么汉尼拔没有赢？这很有趣。我认为相当多的历史学家似乎认为这可能表达了一种真实的传统。即使不是，它之所以具有这种共鸣，我的意思是，它是古代历史中最具标志性的时刻之一，是因为它确实聚焦于这个显而易见的问题。为什么汉尼拔没有利用他的伟大胜利立即向罗马推进？因为我们说过他的家族名“巴卡”意味着闪电。
So why doesn't he strike? And there are various suggestions that have been made as to why he doesn't follow. Mahabal's suggestion. So his men are obviously exhausted. Slaughtering large numbers of enemy is really tiring. I mean, your arms would just be exhausted. Many of his own men are badly wounded. It's been a pulverizing day. On top of that, Rome is, it's about almost 300 miles away. And so Mahabal and his light Numidian cavalry, they could probably have got there in about five days, but it would have taken the infantry a fortnight. And what if Hannibal turns up in front of the walls of Rome and the Romans refuse to capitulate? Hannibal does not have any siege equipment. So he'd have two options.
那么他为什么不进攻呢？关于他为什么不听从马哈巴尔的建议，有各种各样的说法。所以他的士兵显然精疲力竭。屠杀大量敌人真的很累。我的意思是，你的手臂会筋疲力尽。他自己的许多士兵受了重伤。这是令人筋疲力尽的一天。最重要的是，罗马距离这里大约300英里。所以马哈巴尔和他的努米底亚轻骑兵可能在大约五天内到达那里，但步兵需要两周时间。如果汉尼拔出现在罗马城墙前，而罗马人拒绝投降怎么办？汉尼拔没有任何攻城装备。所以他有两个选择。
He could either launch an assault. But if that fails, then it, you know, I mean, that's an embarrassment and it kind of, it wipes out the moral and psychological advantage that he's got from his victory at Can I. Or he could put it under siege, but does he have enough men? Hannibal doesn't he is a long, long way from home. Will he have enough men? Will he have enough materials to bring Rome to her knees by putting her under siege? So all these factors may have weighed on Hannibal's mind, but I think the simplest and likeliest explanation for Hannibal's decision not to immediately go herring off towards Rome is simply that he assumes, in the wake of the calamity that he's inflicted on the Romans, can I, that the Romans are now bound to capitulate.
他可以发动突袭。但如果失败了，那么，你知道，我的意思是，那是一种尴尬，它消除了他在坎尼会战中获得的道德和心理优势。或者他可以围城，但他有足够的兵力吗？汉尼拔离家很远。他会有足够的兵力吗？他会有足够的物资通过围城让罗马屈服吗？所以所有这些因素可能都在汉尼拔的脑海中权衡过，但我认为汉尼拔决定不立即冲向罗马的最简单、最可能的解释是，他只是假设，在他给罗马人造成的坎尼灾难之后，罗马人现在注定会投降。
And is this because, basically, this is, you know, ancient wars, there are expectations and conventions just as with, you know, modern wars or indeed sporting encounters or whatever. And his expectation is when you've lost three battles in a row, you will probably come to terms. And then, you know, both sides will rebuild for the next encounter and have many years' time. And this is the norm. And this is what, you know, this is what most. Most sides do, but of course the Romans don't. We've already established that.
这是因为，基本上，这是古代战争，有期望和惯例，就像现代战争或体育比赛一样。他的期望是，当你连续输掉三场战斗时，你可能会达成协议。然后，你知道，双方都会为下一次遭遇战重建，并有许多年的时间。这是常态。这是大多数。大多数方面都会做的事情，但当然罗马人没有。我们已经确定了这一点。
I mean, those are the rules of war that had governed the conflicts between Carthage and Syracuse, for instance. You suffer a defeat, you do a deal, and then you start again in a few years' time. Yeah, I mean, Hannibal is not naive. I mean, he understands the metal of the Romans very, very well. But he does also have, I think, very immediate reasons for thinking that Roman Rural has finally been broken. Firstly, do the Romans have enough manpower now to carry on the fight? They've lost something like 100,000 men in under two years. I mean, that is a completely crippling loss.
我的意思是，那些是统治迦太基和叙拉古之间冲突的战争规则，例如。你遭受失败，你达成协议，然后你在几年后重新开始。是的，我的意思是，汉尼拔并不天真。我的意思是，他非常、非常了解罗马人的本质。但他确实也有，我认为，非常直接的理由认为罗马人的意志终于被打破了。首先，罗马人现在有足够的人力继续战斗吗？他们在不到两年内损失了大约10万人。我的意思是，那是一个完全瘫痪的损失。
But on top of that, in the wake of Can I, there are plenty of straws in the wind suggesting that Roman Rural is really, really on its uppers. So not everyone in the Roman task force that had been defeated at Can I had actually died. Some, a few had managed to break out through the Carthaginian lines as they kind of pressed in on the captured Romans. and also there were something like 10,000 men who had been left as a reserve in the main Roman camp, which was on the other side of a river from the plain where the battle had been fought. And the fugitives from Can I, some of them had sought refuge in the town of Canai itself, near the battlefield, of course, and others had sought refuge in a second smaller camp that had been built in the rear of the Roman battle lines.
但最重要的是，在坎尼之后，有很多迹象表明罗马人的意志真的处于崩溃边缘。所以并不是所有在坎尼被击败的罗马特遣队的人都死了。一些，少数人设法在迦太基人向被俘的罗马人挤压时突破了迦太基防线，而且还有大约1万人作为预备队留在了主要的罗马营地，该营地位于战斗平原的河流另一侧。坎尼的逃亡者，一些人在坎尼镇本身寻求庇护，当然是在战场附近，另一些人在罗马战线后方建造的第二个较小的营地寻求庇护。
So people should imagine that there's the plane. where the battle is fought. There's this smaller camp where the Roman generals and people have been based before the thing. Then there's a river and on the other side there is a massive Roman military camp. There are 10,000 men in the large camp. There are refugees in the smaller camp. They're separated by this river. So Hannibal in the morning turns his attentions to the Romans who've taken refuge in the town of Canai and in this smaller fort. The fugitives in Cannae are very quickly taken prisoner. Then Hannibal is preparing to move on this on the this small Roman camp, which is of course fortified. I mean, the Romans there can can hope to hold out. And officers in the main Roman camps are on
所以人们应该想象有那个平原。战斗在那里进行。有一个较小的营地，罗马将军和人们在事情发生前就驻扎在那里。然后有一条河，在另一边有一个巨大的罗马军营。大营地里有1万人。小营地里有难民。他们被这条河隔开了。所以汉尼拔在早上将注意力转向了在坎尼镇和这个小堡垒中寻求庇护的罗马人。坎尼的逃亡者很快被俘虏。然后汉尼拔准备进攻这个罗马小营地，当然它是有防御工事的。我的意思是，那里的罗马人可以希望坚持住。而主要罗马营地的军官们在
the other side of the river, they've been urging the fugitives to, you know, to, don't stay there. You're going to be, you know, you're going to be wiped out if you do stay there. Cross the river. Come and join us. You can add to our numbers and hopefully we can kind of get away from here. But the Romans fugitives are so demoralised that ultimately only about 600 make the attempt and manage to get away across the river. And so they and the 10,000 reserves had then managed to march out of the main camp to avoid being cornered by Hannibal's cavalry and they cross the plane and they reach a wall town called Canusium, which is about six miles from the battlefield. So the fact that so few people had wanted to take the risk and escape from that smaller camp to join the large camp, I mean, this to Hannibal is an indicator that Roman morale is broken. But also what then happens in Canusium is another indicator of this. Because even in the relative safety of Canusium, which is a walled town, it's evident that morale is really, really at rock bottom.
河的另一边，他们一直在敦促逃亡者，“不要待在那里。如果你待在那里，你会被消灭的。过河。来加入我们。你可以增加我们的人数，希望我们能从这里逃走。”但罗马逃亡者非常沮丧，最终只有大约600人尝试并设法过河逃脱。所以他们和1万名预备队设法从大营地撤出，以避免被汉尼拔的骑兵包围，他们穿过平原，到达了一个叫卡努西姆（Canusium）的围墙城镇，距离战场约六英里。所以很少有人愿意冒险从那个小营地逃出来加入大营地，这对汉尼拔来说是一个罗马士气崩溃的指标。但随后在卡努西姆发生的事情也是另一个指标。因为即使在卡努西姆这个相对安全的围墙城镇里，很明显士气也真的处于最低点。
So one officer who is the son of a consul, the consul is the kind of the leading magistrate in the republic, he is reported by Hannibal spies to have insisted publicly that all is lost, to quote him, the future has nothing to offer but misery and despair. And there are other officers who again are men of very high birth, high rank, who are said to be planning to flee overseas. You know, they have despaired of the situation. And so Hannibal, when he sees all this, when he hears reports of all this, and he must have heard rumors and things, he must think, well, come on, the Romans are broken now, and they will do a deal. And so he sends, he gets the prisoners together, and he says to the prisoners, 10 of you should go to Rome and you will carry my message. I'm asking for a ransom.
所以一名身为执政官儿子的军官，执政官是共和国的首席行政官，据汉尼拔的间谍报告，他公开坚持认为一切都完了，引用他的话，“未来除了痛苦和绝望，一无所有。”还有其他军官，同样是出身高贵、地位显赫的人，据说正计划逃往海外。你知道，他们对局势感到绝望。所以汉尼拔，当他看到这一切，当他听到所有这些报告时，他一定听到了谣言之类的事情，他一定想，好吧，来吧，罗马人现在崩溃了，他们会达成协议。于是他派人把俘虏召集起来，他对俘虏说：“你们中的10个人去罗马，你们将传达我的信息。我要求赎金。”
and then when I've had the ransom, we can have talks about a long-term peace treaty, which will obviously favour Carthage. Yes, and in the speech that he's recorded as giving, I think it expresses what were almost certainly his real sentiments. So Hannibal is made to say by Livy, I am not waging a war of extermination against the Romans. I am merely contending for honour and empire. My ancestors yielded to Roman valour, so in the first Punic War.
“然后当我收到赎金后，我们可以进行关于长期和平条约的谈判，这显然会对迦太基有利。”是的，在他被记录发表的演讲中，我认为它表达了几乎可以肯定是他的真实情感。所以李维让汉尼拔说：“我不是在对罗马人进行灭绝战争。我只是在为荣誉和帝国而战。我的祖先向罗马人的英勇屈服了，就像在第一次布匿战争中那样。”
Now, in the second Punic War, it is the turn of the Romans to yield to my good fortune and to my valour. And that, I think, is clearly what he thinks will happen. Why wouldn't the Romans choose to negotiate? He doesn't want to wipe them out. He doesn't want to destroy them. He just wants to do to the Romans, what the Romans had done to his own city. And so it seems cast in that light as very reasonable. And for the Romans, this is a fateful turning point, because it is.
“现在，在第二次布匿战争中，轮到罗马人向我的好运和我的英勇屈服了。”我认为，这显然是他认为会发生的事情。为什么罗马人不选择谈判？他不想消灭他们。他不想摧毁他们。他只是想对罗马人做罗马人对他自己的城市所做的事情。所以从这个角度来看，这似乎非常合理。对于罗马人来说，这是一个决定性的转折点，因为它是。
in effect their Lord Halifax moment. Was there any possibility the Romans would accept this deal? Well, the truth is that even as those emissaries, so the 10 Roman prisoners who are going to ask the Romans to ransom them, and also a Carthaginian officer called Cathalow, who is kind of in charge of the whole peace mission, even as they are setting off from Can I to Rome, I think Hannibal has already missed the bus.
实际上是他们的“哈利法克斯勋爵时刻”（Lord Halifax moment）。罗马人有可能接受这个协议吗？嗯，事实是，即使是那些特使，也就是那10名要去请求罗马人赎回他们的罗马俘虏，以及一名负责整个和平使命的迦太基军官卡塔洛（Cathalow），即使他们正从坎尼出发前往罗马，我认为汉尼拔已经错过了时机。
but I think things could have been very different. But I think it is possible that just as you could imagine Lord Halifax rather than Churchill coming to power, you know, in the darkest moment for Britain of the Second World War, and perhaps opening negotiations, which would in turn have led to Britain probably suing for terms, I think it is possible to imagine a situation in which the Romans would have done the same. because when the news of Can I reaches Rome, there understandably are massive displays of grief, but also of dread. So you have women start to mourn the dead. And that's, you know, in any city is an eerie and unearthly sound. And you also start to get impromptu public meetings of Roman citizens gathering together in the forum or, you know, other meeting places to discuss what should be done. And you could see a situation, I think, in which these circumstances kind of snowball
但我认为事情可能会大不相同。但我认为有可能，就像你可以想象哈利法克斯勋爵而不是丘吉尔在第二次世界大战英国最黑暗的时刻掌权，你知道，并可能开启谈判，这反过来会导致英国可能求和，我认为可以想象一种罗马人会做同样事情的情况。因为当坎尼的消息传到罗马时，人们可以理解地表现出巨大的悲痛，但也表现出恐惧。所以妇女们开始哀悼死者。而且，你知道，在任何城市这都是一种怪异和超自然的声音。你还开始看到罗马公民在广场或其他聚会场所自发举行的公开会议，讨论应该做什么。我认为，你可以看到一种情况，在这种情况下，这些情况像滚雪球一样
and it becomes impossible for hawks in the Senate to continue the war. However, the Churchillian role in this story is played by a guy called Fabius Maximus, who is known as the Delaya. Yeah. We talked about him in our previous series, because the previous year in the wake of the defeat of the Romans at Lake Trasamine, another brilliant victory for Hannibal. Fabius had been appointed the Supreme Commander of the Roman forces just for a six-month term, and he had pursued a policy of shadowing Hannibal and never actually engaging him in open battle. And this had proved
变得不可能让元老院中的鹰派继续战争。然而，这个故事中的丘吉尔角色是由一个叫费边·马克西姆斯（Fabius Maximus）的人扮演的，他被称为“拖延者”（The Delayer）。是的。我们在之前的系列中谈到过他，因为前一年在罗马人在特拉西梅诺湖战败后，这是汉尼拔的另一场辉煌胜利。费边被任命为罗马军队的最高指挥官，任期仅六个月，他采取了跟踪汉尼拔、从不与他进行公开战斗的政策。这被证明是
very effective and successful. Obviously, by sending eight legions to go and fight Hannibal and then be wiped out at Can I, the Romans had turned their back on this policy. But now, with the news of can I brought to Rome, it's evident that Fabius's strategy had been the correct one. And so he has a tremendous moral force and he takes full advantage of it. He doesn't have an official position, but people look up to him as the guy who has been proved right. And so what he does is to give an incredible display of Saint-Fouin, of kind of cool and measured confidence. And it wins him the effective command of the city. So what he does is to walk around Rome. He kind of greets people in a totally measured state of mind, as though nothing particularly awful has happened, as though it's just a normal day. He stops the women from staging their displays of mourning. He forbids all these public meetings in which people are kind of venting their fear and distress. And he puts guards on the city walls and particularly on the city gates. And they are there not really to guard against Hannibal, but to stop anyone attempting to fear.
非常有效和成功的。显然，通过派遣八个军团去与汉尼拔作战然后被在坎尼消灭，罗马人背弃了这一政策。但现在，随着坎尼的消息传到罗马，很明显费边的战略是正确的。所以他拥有巨大的道德力量，他充分利用了这一点。他没有官方职位，但人们敬仰他，认为他是被证明正确的人。所以他所做的是展现出令人难以置信的冷静、沉着和自信。这为他赢得了对城市的实际指挥权。所以他所做的是在罗马走动。他以一种完全冷静的心态问候人们，好像没有发生什么特别可怕的事情，好像这只是平常的一天。他阻止妇女举行哀悼仪式。他禁止所有这些人们发泄恐惧和痛苦的公开会议。他在城墙上，特别是城门上设置了守卫。他们在那里并不是为了防范汉尼拔，而是为了阻止任何人试图逃跑。
Lee. And what he also does and the Senate does is to consult the Sibberline books. And the Sibbeline books are very ancient collections of Greek writings. You consult them when Rome is in particularly terrible straits. It's a kind of an awful moment of ritual when this is done. They consult the books and the books say, you must in tomb alive, a gall and a Greek. And this is a terrible. news for the Romans because the Romans do not engage in human sacrifice and it's one of the things that marks them out as a civilised people but they're not going to disobey the Sibboline books and so this is what they do they take them to the cattle market the forum Boarrium and they wall these you know this Greek and this gall up and this is an indicator to the Romans to everyone in Italy and to the Carthaginians that they are going to carry on the fight so the Romans have taken these very drastic measures. Hannibal doesn't turn up at the gates because he's not going to prosecute his advantage. He's not going to press it home. And actually, as the days pass,
他所做的，元老院所做的，是查阅西比林书（Sibylline books）。西比林书是非常古老的希腊著作集。当罗马处于特别可怕的困境时，你会查阅它们。这是一个可怕的仪式时刻。他们查阅了这些书，书上说，你必须活埋一个高卢人和一个希腊人。这对罗马人来说是一个可怕的消息，因为罗马人不进行人祭，这是标志他们为文明人的事情之一，但他们不会违抗西比林书，所以这就是他们所做的，他们把他们带到牛市，广场（Forum Boarium），他们把这个希腊人和这个高卢人围起来，这对罗马人、对意大利的所有人以及对迦太基人来说是一个指标，表明他们将继续战斗。所以罗马人采取了这些非常激烈的措施。汉尼拔没有出现在城门口，因为他不会利用他的优势。他不会坚持到底。而且实际上，随着日子一天天过去，
Roman morale starts to recover a little bit, doesn't it? People start to think, okay, you know, he's not coming. The apocalyptic disaster that we feared is not going to materialise. Yeah. So Fabius has obviously sent scouts out along the roads. They say, no, nobody's coming from Can I. This kind of potential mutiny in Canocium with all the officers. who are kind of panicking and wanting to go abroad. This is put down by a young officer, no more than 19 years old at this point, and he is called Publius Cornelius Scipio, and he's the son of the consul who had confronted Hannibal in the year of his invasion of Italy, and he had drawn his sword, pointed it at his jittery fellow
罗马的士气开始恢复了一点，不是吗？人们开始想，好吧，你知道，他不来了。我们担心的末日灾难不会发生。是的。所以费边显然已经派出了侦察兵沿着道路侦察。他们说，不，没有人从坎尼过来。卡努西姆可能发生的兵变，所有那些惊慌失措并想出国军官，被一名当时年仅19岁的年轻军官平息了，他叫普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·西庇阿（Publius Cornelius Scipio），他是汉尼拔入侵意大利那年与汉尼拔对峙的执政官的儿子，他拔出了剑，指着他那紧张的同伴。
officers, and made them swear an oath, and I quote, never to desert our country, nor permit any other citizen of Rome to leave her in the lurch. So, you know, morale is restored in Canusium. And even the arrival in Rome of one of the two consuls who had been defeated at Can I, which you might think would just plunge people into despondency. Actually, it serves to boost spirits in the city. And this consul who arrives is a guy called Terencius pharaoh. And he, unlike his colleague, who had fallen in the battle, he'd managed to escape the slaughter.
军官们，并让他们宣誓，我引用一下，绝不背弃我们的国家，也不允许任何其他罗马公民将她抛弃。所以，你知道，卡努西姆的士气恢复了。甚至在坎尼战役中战败的两名执政官之一抵达罗马时，你可能认为这会让人们陷入沮丧，但实际上，这反而提振了城中的士气。这位抵达的执政官名叫特伦提乌斯·瓦罗。与他在战斗中阵亡的同事不同，他成功逃脱了那场屠杀。
And he ends up going to Canusium taking charge of the soldiers there. He works hard to get them into fighting order, and then he hands them over to the command of the man who has been sent by the Senate to replace him. And for Varro, the prospect of going back to Rome is obviously a terrible one. I mean, he's presided over the worst defeat in Rome's history. But he does go back, and he's braced to accept whatever punishment the Senate might decree. But the Senate is impressed by his courage in returning to face the music. and so instead it gives him a vote of thanks and the reason for this vote of thanks
他最终前往卡努西姆，接管了那里的士兵。他努力使他们恢复战斗秩序，然后将他们交给参议院派来接替他的人指挥。对于瓦罗来说，回到罗马的前景显然是可怕的。毕竟，他主持了罗马历史上最惨痛的失败。但他还是回去了，并准备接受参议院可能判处的任何惩罚。但参议院对他回来面对后果的勇气印象深刻，因此反而对他表示了感谢，而这次感谢的原因是
he had not despaired of the Republic and so this notion that to despair is the worst of crimes is absolutely enshrined this is the great message that the Romans are proclaiming to the world and not only that but the Romans so when these prisoners arrive so these prisoners who've been sent by Hannibal
他没有对共和国绝望，所以这种“绝望是最大的罪行”的观念被绝对地奉为圭臬，这就是罗马人向世界宣告的伟大信息。不仅如此，当这些囚犯抵达时——也就是汉尼拔派来的那些囚犯——
basically to ask for a ransom and to start the process of negotiations when they turn up outside the city, the Romans don't even let them in, do they? I mean, that's a very, very bold statement of intent. We're not even going to consider talking to you because we're so determined that we fight on. It's a massively hardcore decision because what it means is that the Romans are losing fit men of military age that they might have ransomed and they're very short of fit military men. Individual senators, of course, you know, they would have relatives. They might have sons or brothers or whatever.
基本上是为了请求赎金并开启谈判进程，当他们出现在城外时，罗马人甚至不让他们进城，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个非常、非常大胆的意图声明。我们甚至不会考虑与你们交谈，因为我们决心战斗到底。这是一个极其强硬的决定，因为这意味着罗马人正在失去他们本可以赎回的适龄服役的健康男子，而他们非常缺乏健康的军人。当然，个别参议员，你知道，他们会有亲戚。他们可能有儿子、兄弟之类的。
And sure enough, when the news comes back to Hannibal, I mean, he's furious. And so he sells all the Roman prisoners as slaves. The decision of the Senate not to negotiate also dooms the countryside of Italy, all the villages, the estates, the crops, to what will prove terrible devastation. Year after year, after year. And the reason for this is because the Romans are now absolutely pledged again to the strategy that Fabius had adopted, which is basically avoid meeting Hannibal in battle. Only ever shadow him. In the immediate wake of Can I, they lack the manpower to actually do anything more than that. But I think also it reflects an entirely understandable sense that this man is a genius.
果不其然，当消息传回汉尼拔那里时，他非常愤怒。于是他把所有的罗马囚犯都卖作奴隶。参议院不进行谈判的决定也注定了意大利的乡村、所有的村庄、庄园和农作物将遭受可怕的破坏。年复一年。原因在于罗马人现在再次绝对致力于法比乌斯所采取的战略，即基本上避免与汉尼拔进行正面交战。只对他进行监视。在坎尼战役之后，他们缺乏人力来做更多的事情。但我认为这也反映了一种完全可以理解的感觉，即这个人是个天才。
You know, you meet him in battle. He will destroy you. And the consequence of this is that Hannibal is able to do what he likes to the orchards, to the vineyards, to the estates that cover Italy. And a quick question. So while Hannibal's doing this, so Hannibal is plundering and burning and all of this kind of thing, Why doesn't Rome become completely isolated? Why don't all the other cities of Italy go over to Hannibal? Or actually do they?
你知道，你在战场上遇到他。他会摧毁你。其后果是，汉尼拔可以随心所欲地对待覆盖意大利的果园、葡萄园和庄园。顺便问一下。那么当汉尼拔这样做的时候，也就是汉尼拔在掠夺、焚烧等等的时候，为什么罗马没有被完全孤立？为什么意大利的其他城市没有投靠汉尼拔？或者说，他们投靠了吗？
Why don't they defect now? Because he's going to win. Quite a lot do. Quite a lot think, as you say, they're backing a winner. They see Hannibal as a winner. And so in the wake of Can I, you start to see an Italian league of the kind that the Romans had been at the head of start to emerge that is pledged to support not the Romans any longer, but Hannibal.
为什么他们现在不倒戈？因为他会赢。相当多的人倒戈了。正如你所说，相当多的人认为他们是在押注赢家。他们视汉尼拔为赢家。因此，在坎尼战役之后，你开始看到一种罗马人曾领导的那种意大利联盟开始出现，它承诺支持的不再是罗马人，而是汉尼拔。
and to supply Hannibal with what he so desperately needs because he's a long way from home, namely troops to reinforce his army, supplies, accommodation. And yet, that said, the Romans do still have some advantages, don't they? So if you're a betting man, you're looking at this, the Romans are still on home turf. Hannibal is a long way. I mean, you said he didn't have siege equipment.
并向汉尼拔提供他迫切需要的东西，因为他离家很远，即增援他军队的部队、补给、住宿。然而，话虽如此，罗马人确实还有一些优势，不是吗？所以如果你是一个赌徒，你看着这一切，罗马人仍然在主场。汉尼拔离得很远。我的意思是，你说过他没有攻城装备。
So, you know, he's a long way from Carthage. He's not going to get lots of supplies coming in all the time from Carthage. and if you did abandon the Romans, you're an Italian city, you're taking a hell of a risk, right? Because if the Romans do win, they will destroy you. And so, although there are defections, although Hannibal does manage to set up a kind of Punic league, most of the cities, certainly a majority,
所以，你知道，他离迦太基很远。他不可能一直从迦太基获得大量补给。如果你是一个意大利城市，你背弃了罗马人，你是在冒巨大的风险，对吧？因为如果罗马人赢了，他们会摧毁你。因此，尽管有倒戈，尽管汉尼拔确实设法建立了一种布匿联盟，但大多数城市，当然是绝大多数，
stay loyal to Rome, because the Italians have experience with the Romans. I mean, you know, they're like cockroaches. You just, they just keep coming back. And so as the years pass, Rome starts to recapture its energy, to replenish its manpower, start flexing its muscles, to start to go on the offensive. And by 2.11, so that's five years after Can I. So he's been hanging around in the fields for five years? Well, he hasn't been hanging around in fields because he now has cities that will support him.
仍然忠于罗马，因为意大利人有与罗马人打交道的经验。我的意思是，你知道，他们就像蟑螂。你就是，他们就是不断地卷土重来。随着岁月的流逝，罗马开始恢复活力，补充人力，开始展示其实力，开始转入进攻。到了公元前211年，也就是坎尼战役五年后。所以他在田野里晃荡了五年？嗯，他并没有在田野里晃荡，因为他现在有了支持他的城市。
Right. And the most famous, the most richest, the most prosperous of cities that supports him is a place called Capua, which is the kind of the leading city in the Bay of Naples. So, you know, a brilliant catch for Hannibal. It effectively becomes his capital in Italy. But by 211, the Romans feel that they are ready to advance on Capua and to try and take it back. And they start the siege at a time when Hannibal is distant, besieging another city in the south of Italy. And the news comes to him that the Romans are besieging Capua. And so rather than march directly to the rescue of Capua, he decides instead that he's going to adopt a diversionary tactic, you know, five years on from the Battle of Can I, he decides at last, I am going to march on Rome and hope that this will so alarm the Romans that they will pull their troops back from Capua and pull them back to their home city. And so he arrives in front of the walls of Rome. And of course, it throws the inhabitants of the city into complete disarray. There is widespread panic. There is this famous cry, Hannibal at Portas, Hannibal at the gates,
对。支持他的最著名、最富有、最繁荣的城市是一个叫卡普亚的地方，它是那不勒斯湾的主要城市。所以，你知道，这对汉尼拔来说是一个辉煌的收获。它实际上成为了他在意大利的首都。但到了公元前211年，罗马人觉得他们准备好向卡普亚推进并试图夺回它了。他们在汉尼拔远在意大利南部围攻另一座城市的时候开始了围城。消息传到他那里，说罗马人正在围攻卡普亚。因此，他没有直接去救援卡普亚，而是决定采取一种牵制战术，你知道，在坎尼战役五年后，他终于决定，我要进军罗马，希望这能让罗马人如此惊慌，以至于他们会把军队从卡普亚撤回，撤回他们的家乡城市。于是他抵达了罗马城墙前。当然，这让城里的居民陷入了彻底的混乱。到处都是恐慌。有句名言，“汉尼拔在门口”（Hannibal ad portas），
which becomes one of the most famous phrases in Roman life and culture. But the Senate, unlike the mass of the populace, refused to panic because they know the situation. As you said, Hannibal doesn't have siege equipment. There's no prospect that he'll be able to storm the walls. And what is more, by great good fortune, it so happens that two legions are present in Rome at the time when Hannibal appears before the walls.
这成为了罗马生活和文化中最著名的短语之一。但参议院与大众不同，拒绝恐慌，因为他们了解情况。正如你所说，汉尼拔没有攻城装备。他不可能攻破城墙。而且更重要的是，非常幸运的是，在汉尼拔出现在城墙前时，罗马恰好有两支军团驻守。
And that's about 10,000 men. So there is actually in the upper echelons of the Roman elite, they're not panicking. And in fact, there is a famous story, which regrettably is very late. And so therefore it's probably made up, but it's a good one anyway, that even as Hannibal is camped out on the estates and lands beyond Rome, the Senate are auctioning off the land on which he's camped and that there are lots of buyers for it. So a kind of nice, you know, a nice statement of Roman pluck. And, you know, their song foie is entirely justified because in due course, Hannibal abandons his camp. He leaves Rome. He's off, you know, roaming across Italy again.
大约有10,000人。所以实际上在罗马精英阶层的上层，他们并没有恐慌。事实上，有一个著名的故事，遗憾的是它出现得很晚，所以很可能是编造的，但无论如何它是个好故事，即使汉尼拔在罗马城外的庄园和土地上扎营，参议院也在拍卖他扎营的那块土地，而且有很多买家。这是一种很好的，你知道，罗马人勇气的体现。而且，你知道，他们的信心是完全合理的，因为在适当的时候，汉尼拔放弃了他的营地。他离开了罗马。他走了，你知道，再次在意大利各地游荡。
The city has survived. And what is more, his diversionary tactic doesn't prove successful because shortly after he's marched on Rome, Capua submits and he loses, you know, this essentially what had been his capital. Now, this doesn't really bring Rome any closer to ultimate success, because, you know, he's not. Hannibal is still undefeated, the Romans are still reluctant to meet him in battle, and lots of other cities, lots of other peoples and regions do remain loyal to Hannibal. And so the problem, essentially for both sides now, Hannibal and the Romans, is that neither side really seems to have a route to defeating the other. But I guess for the Romans, I mean, bearing in mind the scale of the disaster they had suffered at Can I? I mean, a stalemate is a kind of victory for Rome. Yeah, but
这座城市幸存了下来。而且更重要的是，他的牵制战术并没有成功，因为在他进军罗马后不久，卡普亚就投降了，他失去了，你知道，这基本上是他曾经的首都。现在，这并没有让罗马更接近最终的胜利，因为，你知道，他没有。汉尼拔仍然未尝败绩，罗马人仍然不愿与他正面交战，而且许多其他城市、许多其他民族和地区仍然忠于汉尼拔。因此，双方——汉尼拔和罗马人——现在面临的问题基本上是，双方似乎都没有击败对方的途径。但我猜对于罗马人来说，考虑到他们在坎尼遭受的灾难规模？我的意思是，僵局对罗马来说是一种胜利。是的，但是
the stalemate will not last because both sides are determined to break it. Certainly, the Romans are. And after the break, we will find out how this extraordinary war, this duel between Hannibal and Rome, takes another twist. With MX Platinum, $400 in annual credits for travel and dining, means you not only satisfy your travel bug, but your taste buds too. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply. Local news is in decline across Canada,
僵局不会持续下去，因为双方都决心打破它。当然，罗马人是这样。休息之后，我们将了解这场非凡的战争，这场汉尼拔与罗马之间的决斗，是如何发生又一次转折的。使用美国运通白金卡，每年400美元的旅行和餐饮积分，意味着你不仅能满足你的旅行瘾，还能满足你的味蕾。这就是美国运通的强大后盾。适用相关条款。加拿大各地的本地新闻正在衰落，
and this is bad news for all of us. With less local news, noise, rumors, and misinformation fill the void, and it gets harder to separate truth from fiction. That's why CBC News is putting more journalists in more places across Canada, reporting on the ground from where you live. telling the stories that matter to all of us. Because local news is big news. Choose news, not noise.
这对我们所有人来说都是坏消息。随着本地新闻的减少，噪音、谣言和错误信息填补了空白，区分事实与虚构变得越来越困难。这就是为什么加拿大广播公司（CBC）新闻正在加拿大各地投入更多的记者，从你居住的地方进行实地报道。讲述对我们所有人来说都很重要的故事。因为本地新闻就是大新闻。选择新闻，而不是噪音。
CBC News. I was guilty of multiple skin care crimes. Two counts of sleeping in makeup, one count of using disposable wipes. I knew my routine had to change. So I switched to Garnier-Missler water. It gently cleanses, perfectly removes makeup, and provides 24-hour hydration.
CBC新闻。我犯了多种护肤罪。两次带妆睡觉，一次使用一次性湿巾。我知道我的护肤程序必须改变。所以我换成了卡尼尔（Garnier）卸妆水。它温和清洁，完美卸妆，并提供24小时保湿。
Clear away the evidence with the number of won Misslerwater worldwide by Garnier. Welcome back to The Rest is History. The Great War between Hannibal and the Romans has degenerated into a stalemate. Hannibal's won his battle at Can I, but he hasn't pressed home his advantage. He hasn't captured Rome. On the other hand, the Romans don't want to face him in battle because they know that he is a formidable opponent.
用全球销量第一的卡尼尔卸妆水清除证据。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。汉尼拔与罗马人之间的伟大战争已经演变成僵局。汉尼拔在坎尼赢得了战斗，但他没有扩大优势。他没有占领罗马。另一方面，罗马人不想在战场上面对他，因为他们知道他是一个强大的对手。
So the question is, how are the Romans, or indeed the Carthaginians, going to break the stalemate and the answer lies not in Rome specifically but in Italy, doesn't it? It's the mastery of Italy that is now the bone of contention. I mean, that's the obvious way for one or other of the competence to win. Because if Hannibal can set himself at the head of an Italian league of cities and peoples and regions and so on that freezes out Rome, then of course, ultimately the Romans will be forced to negotiate. But conversely, if the Romans can deprive Hannibal of Italian backing, then it will deprive him of the bases and the supplies and above all the recruits that he will need to sustain his campaign in Italy. So Italy remains the focus of their combat. But there isn't
所以问题是，罗马人，或者说迦太基人，将如何打破僵局？答案不在罗马，而是在意大利，不是吗？对意大利的控制权现在成了争论的焦点。我的意思是，这是竞争对手之一获胜的显而易见的方式。因为如果汉尼拔能让自己成为一个由意大利城市、民族和地区等组成的联盟的领袖，从而将罗马拒之门外，那么当然，最终罗马人将被迫进行谈判。但反过来，如果罗马人能剥夺汉尼拔的意大利支持，那么这将剥夺他在意大利维持战役所需的基地、补给，尤其是新兵。所以意大利仍然是他们战斗的焦点。但还有
an additional option as well, and that is to expand the war beyond Italy. So obviously, Hannibal is sustained in his war against the Romans by the fact that Carthage has this empire in Spain, with all its reserves of manpower, all its gold and silver and so on. So the Romans are thinking, well, what if we, what if we grab that? I mean, that's an obvious field for them. But for the Carthaginians, they can start to look at an overseas possession of the Romans and think, well, what if we took that? And that, of course, is Sicily, with which the Carthaginians are very familiar,
一个额外的选择，那就是将战争扩大到意大利之外。显然，汉尼拔在对罗马人的战争中得到支持，是因为迦太基在西班牙拥有这个帝国，拥有所有的兵力储备、所有的黄金和白银等等。所以罗马人正在想，嗯，如果我们，如果我们夺取那个地方呢？我的意思是，这对他们来说是一个显而易见的领域。但对于迦太基人来说，他们可以开始审视罗马人的海外领地，并想，嗯，如果我们夺取那个地方呢？那当然就是西西里岛，迦太基人对此非常熟悉，
because they don't possess large swathes of it. They've been fighting endlessly in it. And if they can get Sicily, then that massively weighs the advantage in favor of Hannibal. So the key to Sicily is the city of Syracuse that we mentioned in the first half. It's an ally of Rome, a very loyal ally. The Carthaginians therefore have to think, well, how can we suborn the Syracusans or seduce them or whatever to come over to our side? And if they can do that, then potentially it means that the whole of Sicily can kind of fall into their lap. And Hannibal of all men needs no reminding of how strategically significant Sicily is.
因为他们并不拥有它的大片土地。他们一直在那里无休止地战斗。如果他们能得到西西里岛，那么这将极大地增加汉尼拔的优势。所以西西里岛的关键是我们在上半部分提到的叙拉古城。它是罗马的盟友，一个非常忠诚的盟友。因此，迦太基人必须考虑，嗯，我们怎样才能收买叙拉古人，或者诱惑他们，或者其他什么方式让他们倒向我们这边？如果他们能做到这一点，那么潜在地，这意味着整个西西里岛都可以落入他们的囊中。汉尼拔比任何人都更不需要提醒西西里岛的战略重要性。
That's where his father, Hamilcar, had made his name. The occupation of Sicily by the Romans had been the kind of, you know, the Versailles Treaty type humiliation, the worst of all the humiliations that Carthage had suffered when the Romans defeated them in the previous war. So in a sense, it's the Alsace Lorraine of the Punic Wars. It's very rich. It's strategically vital. And I guess it's doomed to be a bone of contention between Roman Carthage for as long as both of them are great powers. So the key to this is Syracuse.
那是他父亲哈米尔卡成名的地方。罗马人对西西里岛的占领是一种，你知道，凡尔赛条约式的羞辱，是迦太基在上一场战争中被罗马人击败时所遭受的所有羞辱中最糟糕的一次。所以从某种意义上说，它是布匿战争中的阿尔萨斯-洛林。它非常富饶。它在战略上至关重要。我想只要罗马和迦太基都是大国，它就注定会成为两者之间争论的焦点。所以关键在于叙拉古。
Previously, a rival of Carthage, now Rome's junior partner. And Syracuse, I asked you, Greek colony, Greek speaking, very rich, very beautiful. and strategically massively important, isn't it? I mean, Syracuse is basically the key, not just to Sicily, but to control of that part of the Mediterranean. Completely. And it's hard to overestimate its wealth and its splendor in this period. So there was a Roman poet, Silius Italicus,
以前是迦太基的竞争对手，现在是罗马的初级伙伴。而叙拉古，我问过你，希腊殖民地，讲希腊语，非常富有，非常美丽，而且在战略上极其重要，不是吗？我的意思是，叙拉古基本上不仅是西西里岛的关键，也是控制地中海那一部分的关键。完全正确。而且在这一时期，很难高估它的财富和辉煌。所以有一位罗马诗人，西利乌斯·伊塔利库斯（Silius Italicus），
he wrote about the Punic War some three centuries later. And his comment on Syracuse in this period was that in all the earth around which the sun drives his chariot, no city at that time could rival her. And, you know, he's not exaggerating because Syracuse in the decades before Hannibal's war had been given this massive makeover. And it was so spectacular and so exquisite in its consequences that the city, which is very old by this point, so unlike Alexandria, its obvious rival for the title of the most beautiful city in the Greek world. But in a way, Syracuse has been given such an incredible makeover that it's a very important.
他在三个世纪后写了关于布匿战争的作品。他对这一时期叙拉古的评价是，在太阳驾车环绕的所有大地上，当时没有城市能与她媲美。而且，你知道，他并没有夸大其词，因为在汉尼拔战争之前的几十年里，叙拉古进行了大规模的改造。它所产生的后果是如此壮观和精致，以至于这座城市，到目前为止已经非常古老了，所以不像亚历山大港，它在希腊世界最美丽城市称号上的明显竞争对手。但在某种程度上，叙拉古经过了如此令人难以置信的改造，以至于它非常重要。
seems even more modern than Alexandria does. So it has this kind of ancient stone theatre, which has been rebuilt, extended. It's got new temples. It's got gymnasia. It's got incredible marketplaces and shopping centres all over the place. It has the world's largest altar, so massive that 450 oxen could be slaughtered on it simultaneously, and which would have provided half a million people it's been estimated with a very decent size. steak. Wow. So sort of like an Argentine restaurant. Yes, huge gaucho restaurant. It has double harbors. It has shipyards and again all of these have been comprehensively renovated and refurbished. It has impregnable walls which
看起来甚至比亚历山大港更现代。所以它有这种古老的石制剧院，经过了重建和扩建。它有新的神庙。它有体育馆。它到处都有令人难以置信的市场和购物中心。它拥有世界上最大的祭坛，大到可以同时宰杀450头牛，据估计，这可以为50万人提供一份相当不错的牛排。哇。所以有点像阿根廷餐厅。是的，巨大的高乔餐厅。它有双重港口。它有造船厂，而且所有这些都经过了全面的翻新和整修。它有坚不可摧的城墙，
stretched 17 miles and a lot of these walls are snaking up and over mountainous heights. So essentially it's almost impossible for a besieger to invest the city. It has an enormous fortress, the Uriolus, which is set on the highest point of the city walls and dominates the land approaches to Syracuse, and even the very oldest part of the city, which is an island called Ortegia, so just off the mainland. This is where the first colonists from Corinth had settled, who founded Carthage. This now boasts a really sumptuous, magnificent palace, a palace that can rival the palace in Alexandria. And the bloke who has paid for all this, or has commissioned it, the bloke who's been running Syracuse for the last.
绵延17英里，其中许多城墙蜿蜒在山峦之上。所以基本上，围攻者几乎不可能包围这座城市。它有一个巨大的堡垒，尤里奥鲁斯（Euryalus），它坐落在城墙的最高点，俯瞰着通往叙拉古的陆路，甚至城市最古老的部分，也就是奥提伽岛（Ortygia），就在大陆旁边。这是来自科林斯的最初殖民者定居的地方，他们建立了迦太基。这里现在拥有一个非常豪华、宏伟的宫殿，一个可以与亚历山大港的宫殿相媲美的宫殿。而为这一切买单，或者委托建造它的人，过去一直在管理叙拉古的人，
few decades is this guy who used to be, he's a hard man, isn't he, is an ex-captain of mercenaries called Hieron. And he's, he's incredibly old, especially by classical standards. He's like, he's almost 90. Well, yes. So by the time that Hannibal launches his invasion of Italy, Huron is in his late 80s. And he has been in charge of the city since the two 70s. So, I mean, that is a very, very long period of office. And it reflects the fact that he is a very, very wily, astute man who is able to capitalize on two tremendous advantages. And the first of these is the alliance with Rome. It's Huron who kind of says, we are sticking to Rome through thick and thin. Although he was a mercenary, and although it's
过去几十年来，就是这个家伙，他是一个硬汉，不是吗，是一个叫希伦（Hieron）的前雇佣兵队长。而且他，他非常老，尤其是以古典标准来看。他几乎90岁了。嗯，是的。所以当汉尼拔发动对意大利的入侵时，希伦已经80多岁了。他从公元前270年代就开始管理这座城市。所以，我的意思是，那是一个非常、非常长的任期。这反映出他是一个非常、非常狡猾、精明的人，能够利用两个巨大的优势。其中第一个是与罗马的联盟。是希伦说，我们无论如何都要坚持与罗马站在一起。虽然他曾是一名雇佣兵，虽然
kind of, you know, for centuries been the national sport of the Greeks in Sicily to fight each other, hereon actually isn't a great man for war. He's a man of peace. And the Roman alliance enables him to enjoy decades of peace. And so the money that previous leaders of Syracuse would have squandered on pointless wars, you know, with Carthage or with other Greek cities or whatever, hereon is able to spend this wealth on beautifying Syracuse and on growing the economy. So, you know, by expanding the harbors or whatever, he makes Syracuse richer and more productive.
你知道，几个世纪以来，西西里岛的希腊人互相争斗一直是他们的民族运动，但希伦实际上并不是一个好战的人。他是一个和平主义者。罗马的联盟使他能够享受几十年的和平。因此，叙拉古以前的领导人会浪费在毫无意义的战争上的钱，你知道，与迦太基或其他希腊城市之类的战争，希伦能够把这些财富花在美化叙拉古和发展经济上。所以，你知道，通过扩建港口之类的，他使叙拉古变得更富有、更具生产力。
And even the defeats of Rome at first late Trasamine and then Can I cannot persuade him to budge in his loyalty to Rome. So in the wake of Can I, he sends the Romans grain, he sends them troops, he sends them financial subsidies. The special relationship holds rock solid. So that's the first advantage that Huron feels he has. There is another advantage, and that is the fact that he has in Syracuse, one of the great genius. of history. And this is a man called Archimedes. And Dominic, I know you love, you love a mathematician and an engineer, don't you? And Archimedes is, I mean, he's kind of hailed by Leonardo, by Galileo, by Newton, as the greatest, the goat. And he's famous above all for being in his bath,
即使是罗马在特拉西梅诺湖和坎尼的失败，也无法说服他动摇对罗马的忠诚。所以在坎尼战役之后，他向罗马人运送粮食，向他们派遣军队，向他们提供财政补贴。这种特殊关系坚如磐石。这就是希伦认为他拥有的第一个优势。还有另一个优势，那就是他在叙拉古拥有历史上最伟大的天才之一。这个人叫阿基米德。多米尼克，我知道你喜欢，你喜欢数学家和工程师，对吧？而阿基米德，我的意思是，他被列奥纳多、伽利略、牛顿誉为最伟大的人，史上最强（GOAT）。他最出名的是在浴缸里，
suddenly realizing about the displacement of water or some such, very boring scientific principle, and shouting Eureka and running through the streets, I'm going to guess this never happened or, you know, he didn't do anything like this. Is that correct? I mean, it is absolutely one of the most famous stories in science up there with, you know, an apple hitting Newton on the head. And it does actually feature hereon, the ruler of Syracuse, who, according to a much later writer, was actually a kinsman of Archimedes.
突然意识到水的浮力或某种类似的、非常无聊的科学原理，然后大喊“尤里卡”（Eureka），并跑过街道。我猜这从来没有发生过，或者，你知道，他没有做过类似的事情。这是正确的吗？我的意思是，这绝对是科学界最著名的故事之一，与牛顿被苹果砸到头的故事并列。而且它确实涉及叙拉古的统治者希伦，根据一位后来的作家的说法，他实际上是阿基米德的亲戚。
So, you know, that would suggest a kind of closeness between them. So the story goes, and I know that, I can see the excitement on your face at the prospect of a... Yeah, give me a scientific lecture. Yeah. So, hereon has commissioned a golden wreath as an offering to the gods.
所以，你知道，这表明他们之间有一种亲密关系。故事是这样的，我知道，我能看到你脸上对……的期待。是的，给我讲个科学讲座。是的。所以，希伦委托制作了一个金花环作为给神的祭品。
And this wreath is delivered by the craftsman and it weighs exactly what it's supposed to weigh. But hereon, very stute man, he suspects that he's being ripped off and that what seems to be pure gold might actually contain quite a lot of silver that it's been debased. and so he gets Archimedes on the case, obvious person to turn to.
这个花环由工匠送来，重量完全符合要求。但希伦，一个非常精明的人，他怀疑自己被坑了，看起来是纯金的东西实际上可能含有大量的白银，它被掺假了。所以他让阿基米德来处理这件事，这是显而易见的人选。
And Archimedes retires to his bathtub to ponder the problem. And to quote Nicholas Nicastro in his fantastic book on Archimedes just come out, Archimedes' fulcrum of science. As Archimedes sank into his tub, he perceived that the water he displaced was equal to the volume of his body he had submerged, not his weight. So, to the degree that I understand it, what then happens is that Archimedes takes. a bar of gold and a bar of silver and each one is equal exactly in weight to the wreath and he puts them both in his bathtub and he then puts the wreath in the bathtub and the wreath displaces more water than the gold had done but less than the silver and therefore this shows that the wreath was indeed made of adulterated gold that it had the gold had been mixed with silver.
阿基米德退到浴缸里思考这个问题。引用尼古拉斯·尼卡斯特罗（Nicholas Nicastro）在他那本关于阿基米德的精彩著作《阿基米德的科学支点》（Archimedes' Fulcrum of Science）中的话，当阿基米德沉入浴缸时，他意识到他排出的水等于他浸入身体的体积，而不是他的重量。所以，据我所知，接下来发生的事情是，阿基米德拿了一块金条和一块银条，每一块的重量都与花环完全相等，他把它们都放进浴缸里，然后他把花环放进浴缸，花环排出的水比金条多，但比银条少，因此这表明花环确实是由掺假的金子制成的，金子被掺入了白银。
I kind of understand that vaguely and I gather from Nicholas Nicastro that there are various in probabilities about this. I don't entirely understand. But maybe they can tackle it on the rest of the science. I don't know. Anyway, so that's the story. But Archimedes isn't just messing around with reeds and gold, is he? I mean, he's designing military stuff, right? Like a galley that ends up being given to Ptolemy the third? Yeah. And the castoros says that, I mean, this is kind of like the Titanic, but it was longer and heavier than HMS victory. Crikey. It's huge. It's Archimedes who's built the city walls. and done so, you know, with such brilliance that they're effectively impregnable.
我隐约理解这一点，我从尼古拉斯·尼卡斯特罗那里了解到，关于这个故事有各种各样的不可信之处。我不太明白。但也许他们可以在《历史的其余部分》的科学版块中讨论它。我不知道。总之，这就是故事。但阿基米德不仅仅是在摆弄花环和金子，对吧？我的意思是，他在设计军事装备，对吧？比如送给托勒密三世的一艘桨帆船？是的。卡斯托罗斯说，我的意思是，这有点像泰坦尼克号，但它比胜利号（HMS Victory）更长、更重。天哪。它太大了。是阿基米德建造了城墙，
But most excitingly of all, he's designed a massive array of kind of futuristic war machines. So massive catapults. Missile launches called scorpions, so, you know, the sting in the tail that you can fire through very narrow slits. Giant mechanical claws, which can reach out from the walls and pick up ships. And even it is said, a death ray. And we'll come in due course to, to whether this death ray actually existed. And Heron loves them. I mean, he can't get enough of these kind of war machines.
并且做得，你知道，如此出色，以至于它们实际上是坚不可摧的。但最令人兴奋的是，他设计了一系列巨大的、某种未来派的战争机器。巨大的投掷机。被称为“蝎子”的导弹发射器，所以，你知道，尾部的毒刺，你可以通过非常狭窄的缝隙射击。巨大的机械爪，可以从城墙伸出来抓起船只。甚至据说，还有一种死亡射线。我们以后会讨论这种死亡射线是否真的存在。希伦很喜欢它们。我的意思是，他无法满足于这些战争机器。
He's a man of peace, so he doesn't actually want to use them, but he's hoping that they will prove a deterrence. And so for decades and decades, they do prove a deterrence, which is kind of sad for Archimedes, because I guess he'd like to see whether they'd actually work. But fortunately for Archimedes, unfortunately for Huron, in 215, everything changes, Huron dies and by this point he is 92 years old. And he's succeeded by his grandson, who's a guy
他是一个和平主义者，所以他实际上不想使用它们，但他希望它们能起到威慑作用。所以几十年来，它们确实起到了威慑作用，这对阿基米德来说有点悲哀，因为我猜他想看看它们是否真的有效。但幸运的是对于阿基米德，不幸的是对于希伦，在公元前215年，一切都变了，希伦去世了，此时他已经92岁了。继位的是他的孙子，一个叫
called Hieronymus, and he is still only a teenager. He's very headstrong, he's very inexperienced, and he fatally is persuaded by an anti-Roman faction in the city that Rome is doomed and that he should open negotiations with Carthage. Oh, that's a big twist. It's in the wake of Can I. You can see why they would do it. But the pro-Roman faction, which is very strong in Syracuse, they immediately have Hieronymus assassinated and there's a low-level civil war, a republic is proclaimed, the pro-Carthage faction triumphs, and it opens negotiations with Hannibal, and it starts to launch raids on Roman-held territory in Sicily. And this Dominic proves to be, for Syracuse, an absolutely calamitous mistake. Hereon had been right. You know, it is. It is a very important. It is,
希罗尼穆斯（Hieronymus）的家伙，他还是个十几岁的少年。他非常固执，非常缺乏经验，而且致命的是，他被城里的反罗马派系说服，认为罗马注定要失败，他应该与迦太基开启谈判。哦，那是一个巨大的转折。那是在坎尼战役之后。你可以看出他们为什么会这样做。但叙拉古非常强大的亲罗马派系立即暗杀了希罗尼穆斯，随后发生了低强度的内战，共和国被宣布成立，亲迦太基派系获胜，它开启了与汉尼拔的谈判，并开始对西西里岛的罗马控制领土发动袭击。多米尼克，这对叙拉古来说被证明是一个绝对灾难性的错误。希伦是对的。你知道，它是。它是
is the worst policy imaginable to take on the Romans, even as they are kind of battered by all the losses of manpower that they've been suffering at the hands of Hannibal. Not least because the Roman, the top Roman in Sicily, who's called Claudius Marcellus, he is a very formidable person, isn't he? He had killed a king of the Gauls in single combat and had won the Spolia, what's that, the Spolia Apimer, which is the greatest prize that any Roman could hope to have. So you kill your enemy general in combat and you strip him of his armor. And it's just tremendous glory. And this is what Marcellus has done. He's been consul for, you know, for five times. He's quite a cultured man. You know, he's a lover of Greek culture.
采取与罗马人对抗的政策是你能想象到的最糟糕的政策，即使他们正被汉尼拔造成的巨大兵力损失所打击。尤其是因为西西里岛的最高罗马长官，名叫克劳迪乌斯·马塞卢斯（Claudius Marcellus），他是一个非常可怕的人，不是吗？他在单挑中杀死了高卢人的国王，并赢得了“斯波利亚·奥皮马”（Spolia Opima），那是什么，这是任何罗马人所能希望得到的最高奖赏。所以你在战斗中杀死了敌方将军，并剥夺了他的盔甲。这真是巨大的荣耀。这就是马塞卢斯所做的。他担任执政官已经，你知道，五次了。他是一个相当有文化的人。你知道，他是一个希腊文化的爱好者。
He will prove to be a great admirer of Archimedes. But he's absolutely not someone to mess with. So he's described in the later biography as a man of war with a body hewn from granite and a sword arm. of devastating power. And this is the guy in the spring of 213 who appears before the walls of Syracuse at the head of a large army of Romans, many of whom are veterans of Can I, so those 10,000 who had survived Can I, and who are therefore desperate for revenge. They camp out before the walls of Syracuse and on the seaside, Marcellus gets on board his galley and leads a battle fleet into the harbours of the city. So it's a kind of pincer movement. And the Syracusans understandably are terrified.
他将被证明是阿基米德的崇拜者。但他绝对不是一个好惹的人。所以他在后来的传记中被描述为一个战争狂人，身体由花岗岩雕刻而成，挥舞着具有毁灭性力量的剑。这就是在公元前213年春天，率领一支庞大的罗马军队出现在叙拉古城墙前的人，其中许多人是坎尼战役的老兵，也就是那10,000名在坎尼幸存下来的人，因此他们渴望复仇。他们在叙拉古城墙前扎营，而在海边，马塞卢斯登上了他的桨帆船，率领一支战斗舰队进入了城市的港口。所以这是一种钳形攻势。叙拉古人理所当然地感到恐惧。
But this is the moment when Archimedes and his war machines come into their own. Bring out the scorpions. Bring out the scorpions. Bring out the catapults. And the scorpions and the catapults are incredibly effective, right? They absolutely bombard the Roman besiegers. And isn't the story that basically, you know, they were so terrifying that soon afterwards, if you're a Roman infantryman and you saw a little bit of rope,
但这就是阿基米德和他的战争机器发挥作用的时刻。把蝎子拿出来。把蝎子拿出来。把投掷机拿出来。蝎子和投掷机非常有效，对吧？它们绝对轰炸了罗马围攻者。故事不是说基本上，你知道，它们太可怕了，以至于不久之后，如果你是一个罗马步兵，你看到一小段绳子，
being waved behind the walls or a bit of wood, you would run away in terror because you thought it might be the scorpion again. Yeah, or some fresh hellish contraption that Archimedes has come up with. And at the same time, the Roman Fleet 2 is getting absolutely battered. So we mentioned how there are these giant mechanical claws. A later historian describes how these mechanical claws operated. A ship would be seized by its prowl, lifted up into the air, then dropped into the depths or spun round and round and smashed into the steep cliffs that jutted out beneath the wall of the city. And sometimes we're told the ships would be shaken up and down until its crew had been thrown out and hurled in all directions.
在城墙后面挥舞，或者一块木头，你就会惊恐地逃跑，因为你以为那可能是蝎子又来了。是的，或者阿基米德想出的某种新的地狱般的装置。与此同时，罗马舰队也遭到了沉重的打击。所以我们提到了这些巨大的机械爪。一位后来的历史学家描述了这些机械爪是如何操作的。一艘船会被它的船头抓住，被吊到空中，然后扔进深渊，或者被旋转、旋转，撞向城墙下突出的陡峭悬崖。有时我们被告知，船只会被上下摇晃，直到船员被甩出并向四面八方抛去。
And there is also, according to a guy called Anthemius of Tralez, a unanimous tradition that Archimedes used mirrors to direct the sun's rays at the enemy fleet and incinerate it. So this is the death ray. and do people think that these death ray machines genuinely existed and worked or not? Sadly not. So Anthemius was writing about 600 years after the siege. And I think the feeling among historians of science is that the stories of this kind of, you know, the mirrors being used to generate death rays was probably inspired by a treatise
根据一个叫特拉勒斯的安特米乌斯（Anthemius of Tralles）的人的说法，还有一个一致的传统，即阿基米德使用镜子将太阳光线对准敌方舰队并将其焚毁。这就是死亡射线。人们认为这些死亡射线机器真的存在并起作用吗？遗憾的是没有。所以安特米乌斯是在围城战600年后写的。我认为科学史学家们的看法是，这种关于镜子被用来产生死亡射线的故事，可能是受到了一篇
that Archimedes had written about mirrors in which he did talk about using them. to channel the rays of the sun to start fires. And then it attains its kind of canonical form, you know, many, many hundreds of years later in the Byzantine era. And this is a period from the walls of Constantinople. They're using Greek fire. And so you can see how perhaps this story, you know, by process of endless elaboration, comes to take on the form it does.
阿基米德写的关于镜子的论文的启发，他在论文中确实谈到了使用它们来引导太阳光线以引发火灾。然后它在许多、许多百年后的拜占庭时代获得了某种规范的形式。这是君士坦丁堡城墙的时期。他们正在使用希腊火。所以你可以看出这个故事是如何通过无休止的润色过程，最终形成了现在的样子。
So I think, sadly, that's probably not true. But I think the essentials are true. Archimedes did devise these kind of innovative, terrifying war machines. they did keep the Romans at bay and Marcellus himself, you know, I mean he's annoyed that they're being kept at bay by these war machines, but he's also incredibly impressed and becomes a great admirer of Archimedes. And so Marcellus decides, well, we can't defeat Archimedes and these war machines, so we're going to have to starve Syracuse. But this is a massive problem because, you know, Archimedes has built these huge walls that go on for 17 miles. So that doesn't really
所以我认为，遗憾的是，那可能不是真的。但我认为基本事实是真的。阿基米德确实设计了这些创新的、可怕的战争机器。它们确实让罗马人望而却步，而马塞卢斯本人，你知道，我的意思是，他很恼火他们被这些战争机器挡住了，但他也非常钦佩，并成为了阿基米德的崇拜者。所以马塞卢斯决定，嗯，我们无法击败阿基米德和这些战争机器，所以我们必须饿死叙拉古。但这是一个巨大的问题，因为，你知道，阿基米德建造了这些绵延17英里的巨大城墙。所以这并不
prove possible. So instead, the Romans just way camped out in front of. of Syracuse waiting for an opportunity. And it arrives eight months before the walls of Syracuse because there is a festival. The Romans notice that the guards are distracted. They bring up ladders. They climb up. They pour over the outer walls and into the outer reaches of the city. But there are still more walls within.
证明是可能的。因此，罗马人只是在叙拉古前扎营等待机会。机会在围城八个月后到来了，因为有一个节日。罗马人注意到守卫分心了。他们架起梯子。他们爬了上去。他们涌过外墙，进入了城市的外部区域。但里面还有更多的城墙。
These are still protected. They're massive. They've got war machines and scorpions and whatnot. So it's only eight months after that that the Romans finally succeed in capturing the whole city, so it's taken them essentially a year and a half. And Marcellus has said, yeah, you can loot the city, do what you want with it. The only thing I want is I want Archimedes captured, because, and to quote a biographer of Marcellus, he reckoned that to save such a great man would redound as much to his glory as would the capture of Syracuse. But they don't capture him, do they?
这些仍然受到保护。它们是巨大的。它们有战争机器和蝎子之类的东西。所以直到八个月后，罗马人才最终成功占领了整座城市，所以他们基本上花了一年半的时间。马塞卢斯说，是的，你们可以掠夺这座城市，随你们怎么做。我唯一想要的是阿基米德被俘虏，因为，引用马塞卢斯的一位传记作者的话，他认为拯救这样一位伟人将像占领叙拉古一样为他带来荣耀。但他们没有抓住他，对吧？
They don't. So Archimedes is among the dead. And I think the story that is told of how he came to Perish is a salutary warning to anyone doing maths that it can be very, very dangerous. So the story goes that Archimedes is busy doing a geometrical puzzle. He's doing it in the sand, you know, with a ruler. A soldier comes up to him. Archimedes tells him to go away. The soldier is infuriated, draws his sword, and hacks Archimedes to death. Do you know who should heed that lesson, Rishi Sunak?
他们没有。所以阿基米德在死者之列。我认为关于他如何丧生的故事是对任何做数学的人的一个有益的警告，它可能非常、非常危险。故事是这样的，阿基米德正忙着做一个几何难题。他用尺子在沙地上做。一名士兵走到他面前。阿基米德叫他走开。士兵被激怒了，拔出剑，把阿基米德砍死了。你知道谁应该吸取那个教训吗？里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）。
He wanted everybody to do maths to the age of about 30 or something, didn't he? You see, this is the benefit of a classical education. If he'd had that, he would have learned that was very foolish. They didn't, they clearly, you know, didn't learn this at Winchester, sadly. So for Marcellus, it's quite a bittersweet moment. You know, he's got Syracuse, but he's lost Archimedes. And we're told by Livy, when he stood on the heights above the city and looked down at Syracuse. In those days, the most beautiful, perhaps in all the world, he is said to have wept, partly for joy that he had succeeded and pulling off such a feat, partly in mourning for the city's ancient glory.
他想让每个人都学数学到30岁左右，不是吗？你看，这就是古典教育的好处。如果他接受过那种教育，他就会知道那是很愚蠢的。他们显然，你知道，遗憾的是在温彻斯特没有学到这一点。所以对于马塞卢斯来说，这是一个苦乐参半的时刻。你知道，他得到了叙拉古，但他失去了阿基米德。李维（Livy）告诉我们，当他站在城市上方的高处俯瞰叙拉古时。在那些日子里，它可能是世界上最美丽的城市，据说他哭了，部分是因为他成功完成了这样一项壮举而感到高兴，部分是因为哀悼这座城市古老的荣耀。
But I think probably there's not much doubt, really. he's weeping for joy. I mean, you know, he's really thrilled because Syracuse is by far the richer city that a Roman army has ever captured. The whole of Sicily is now securely under Roman rule and the hopes that Hannibal had had of seizing it back from Rome, dead toast now.
但我认为可能真的没什么疑问。他是喜极而泣。我的意思是，你知道，他真的很激动，因为叙拉古是罗马军队有史以来占领的最富有的城市。整个西西里岛现在牢牢地处于罗马的统治之下，汉尼拔从罗马手中夺回它的希望，现在彻底破灭了。
All right, so you might think this is the beginning of the end for Carthage. But no, it's not even the end of the beginning, is it? Because one year on from the fall of Syracuse, Hannibal will launch his march. on Rome and in Spain the Roman attempt to intervene there and change the course of the war
好吧，所以你可能认为这是迦太基末日的开始。但不是，这甚至不是开始的结束，对吧？因为在叙拉古陷落一年后，汉尼拔将发动他对罗马的进军，而在西班牙，罗马试图在那里进行干预并改变战争进程
is not going to end well at all with two Roman armies wiped out in succession so it's still all to play for the outcome of the war very much in the balance who is going to win Hannibal or the Romans and how are they going to do it there is only one way you can find out because we will be telling the story in the next three epic episodes of the rest is history
结果一点也不好，两支罗马军队相继被消灭，所以一切都还有变数，战争的结果非常悬而未决，谁会赢？汉尼拔还是罗马人？他们将如何做到这一点？只有一种方法可以找到答案，因为我们将在《历史的其余部分》接下来的三集史诗中讲述这个故事。
you can hear those episodes right away by going to the Restis History.com and joining our own battle-scarred band of mercenaries. The Rest is History Club. Tom, thank you so much for that. I can't wait for the next episode and find out what happens next. Who can say? Yeah, who can say. Goodbye.
你可以通过访问 TheRestisHistory.com 并加入我们那支伤痕累累的雇佣兵乐队——《历史的其余部分》俱乐部，立即收听这些剧集。汤姆，非常感谢你。我迫不及待地想听下一集，看看接下来会发生什么。谁说得准呢？是的，谁说得准呢。再见。
Bye-bye. Tom, we have some absolutely unbelievable news to share with our listeners. Probably the most exciting news who ever shared, no? Oh, I mean, no dispute. This is the most exciting news of all time. Right. So we are announcing the launch of some brand new Rest is History merchandise. And the important thing about this is that it is exclusively for you, the members.
再见。汤姆，我们有一些绝对令人难以置信的消息要与我们的听众分享。可能是我们分享过的最令人兴奋的消息，不是吗？哦，我的意思是，毫无争议。这是有史以来最令人兴奋的消息。对。所以我们宣布推出一些全新的《历史的其余部分》周边商品。而关于这一点重要的事情是，它是专门为你，也就是会员们准备的。
Nobody else will be able to get this. That's absolutely right. So these are T-shirts that have been designed by one of our beloved Athelstands, Graham Johnson. And what he's done is to do designs for six of the biggest series that we have coming up over the next few months. Yes. So it's exclusive merch for our members. And the very first iteration is this amazing T-shirt. It really is a wonderful design.
其他人是买不到的。完全正确。这些T恤是由我们敬爱的Athelstan成员之一Graham Johnson设计的。他为我们未来几个月即将推出的六个重磅系列节目设计了图案。没错。这是我们会员的专属周边。第一款就是这件令人惊叹的T恤。它的设计真的很棒。
It's showing Hannibal as Hercules, crossing the Alps on an elephant. It's beautifully imagined, I have to say, and I would wear it with enormous pride myself. And it's so good that it has a Roman hydra with lots of different heads. Hannibal's chopped off some of them, but there are others with Roman helmets on. I mean, it could not be more epic. Epic is the word. Now, if you want to show your epic status as a member of the Restis History Club, I think it's important for you to wear one of these t-shirts.
它展示了汉尼拔化身为赫拉克勒斯，骑着大象翻越阿尔卑斯山。我不得不说，这个构思非常精妙，我自己都会非常自豪地穿上它。它设计得太好了，上面还有一只长着许多头的罗马九头蛇。汉尼拔砍掉了一些头，但还有一些头上戴着罗马头盔。我的意思是，这简直史诗感爆棚。史诗就是最好的形容词。现在，如果你想展示你作为“历史余味”俱乐部成员的史诗地位，我觉得穿上这件T恤非常重要。
So when you're going out around town, when you see people, if you want to impress your husband or wife, wear this t-shirt or wear multiple t-shirts. Get several, if you can. And you'll want to know how to get hold of it. The way you get to get hold of it is this. You go to the new, exciting Rest is History website, log in and go to the member's merch section. And Tom, what about if you're an Apple member? Because I want to get this absolutely right. I'm going to read out what I have been given.
所以当你出门逛街，或者想给你的丈夫或妻子留下深刻印象时，穿上这件T恤，或者多穿几件。如果可以的话，多买几件。你肯定想知道怎么买到它。获取方式如下：登录我们全新且令人兴奋的“历史余味”网站，进入会员周边专区。Tom，如果是Apple会员该怎么办？因为我想确保信息准确，我来读一下我收到的说明。
If you're an Apple member, you will need to join our members' mailing list to get access. Just send an email to the rest is history at goalhanger.com with Apple member in the subject line and a screenshot of your membership. And we will add you in. And honestly, that couldn't be easier, could it, Dominic? No. So that's the rest is history at goalhanger.com with Apple member in the subject line. Now, what if you're not a member of the show, or not yet a member of the show, I should say? Well, this is a wonderful opportunity for you to put that right and to get that.
如果你是Apple会员，你需要加入我们的会员邮件列表才能获得购买权限。只需发送电子邮件至therestisistory@goalhanger.com，并在主题栏注明“Apple member”，同时附上你的会员资格截图。我们就会把你加进去。说实话，这再简单不过了，对吧，Dominic？没错。所以地址是therestisistory@goalhanger.com，主题栏注明“Apple member”。那么，如果你还不是节目的会员，或者应该说还没成为会员呢？这是一个绝佳的机会让你加入并参与其中。
involved with the show. So not only will you be able to get your hands on this unique and uniquely cool example of merch, but you'll also get all the great benefits, early access to series, bonus episodes, exclusive new miniseries, and so much more. I mean, those are just sensational benefits. Not only do you get to wear a Hannibal themed t-shirt, but there is so much else. So don't hang around, sign up. Head to the rest is history.com. Bye bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
参与到节目中来。这样你不仅能买到这件独特且酷炫的周边，还能享受到所有超棒的福利，比如抢先收听系列节目、额外剧集、独家迷你剧等等。我的意思是，这些福利简直太棒了。你不仅能穿上汉尼拔主题的T恤，还能获得这么多其他权益。所以别犹豫了，快来注册吧。前往therestisistory.com。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。